some more Marvel news so blade has lost
its director Bassam Tariq will no longer
be directing blade starring mahershala
Ali now the exact reason for this is
vaguely worded the statement from Marvel
says that it's due to a shifting
production schedule which would imply a
scheduling conflict but they're two
months away from shooting and that feels
like a cover now I don't want to
speculate as to whether there's another
reason but this is going to put the
production in a tough spot this is
actually fairly reminiscent of when
Edgar Wright left Ant-Man and they had
to scramble for a director or lose all
the pre-production time enough to push
everything back which is expensive to do
and they obviously want to avoid any
director that they got that they come in
is basically just going to be making
whatever film basant Tariq would have
made more or less they're not going to
have time to reshape it into their own
thing which makes me more nervous about
a film that I was otherwise pretty
excited for we'll have to wait and see